- [Voiceover] Horses are
a merit to your soul.
They have feelings, you
know? They understand you.
And to be able to have that
special bond with a horse,
I think is very, very special.
My name's Andrew Lakeman
and I'm a racehorse trainer.
I think from a very young
age I wanted to be a jockey.
I was riding as an apprentice in England
and I got the opportunity to come over
to the United States to work for a
very famous trainer in Maryland.
Unfortunately, in 2007
I was riding a horse on the grass
at Belmont Park and my horse clipped heels
and I went down and
had a horrific accident
which left me paralyzed.
The doctor was very direct.
He told me that I will never walk again.
That feeling really hit me then,
thinking I was never gonna ride again.
What am I gonna do with my life?
When I was recovering,
I had in my mind
I couldn't give up.
I wanted to find my own independence
and I wanted to train.
That's what I did.
I bought my own horse,
I started out with him and I trained him
and I won with him.
Working with the horses,
it's kind of like,
they know that I'm in a wheelchair.
They kind of sense what's going on.
They would never hurt
me. I can go in the stall
and I can check their leg.
You know, a lot of people
would think that they would
jump away from the wheelchair,
they would be afraid.
But no, they were like,
really understanding
and caring, you know, around me.
You know, I'm grateful
for a lot of things,
but I think the most thing
I'm grateful for are horses
because they've given me
everything in my life.
And then after the
accident, they continued to
give me a new life.